what the reason why when somebody calls
somebody average that's usually
perceived to be an insult right I think
we hear it that way we give it that way
nobody's ever told somebody that there's
their average is like a nice thing to
say to somebody now we can say that like
oh well average is most people are
average kind of but also not really
right if you look at like an average
person like an average person has 1.9
legs because some people are missing
legs but no human has 1.9 legs you have
two or one right when we look at who we
are as people there are some things that
we excel at and there are some things
that we don't do anything at so I think
that's why we never feel average right
because we're above average hopefully at
whatever our competency is in So when
you say that somebody's average is
always going to be perceived as an
insult so I'm sure that uh Camilla or
anybody else you guys all had crazy
degree you guys are all more educated
than I am right I'm sure that on a whole
you might be an average person but
you're not going to perceive yourself
that way because you push yourself
forward in some areas that make you not
average and hopefully you're looking for
other people to plug into that those
above average